Here’s my answer. The wordset is just like before.
Read the file, uppercase it, and split it.
In the prefixset, we go through each word in the wordset
and then each prefix of the word, and collect that set p of prefixes and then return them.
Now let’s see what these prefixes can do for us.
I can define a new version of find_words(),
and what this one is it looks exactly like the one before
except what we do at each level of the loop is we add one statement that says,
if the word that we built up so far is not one of the prefixes of a word in the dictionary,
then there’s no sense doing any of these nested loops.
We can continue onto the next iteration of the current loop,
and that's what the continue statement says is
don't do anything below, rather go back to the for loop
that we’re nested in and go through the next iteration of that for loop.
Normally, I don’t like the continue statement and normally, instead of saying
if w not in prefixes continue, I would've said if w in prefixes then do this,
but that would’ve introduced another level of indentation for each of these seven levels
and I’d be running off the edge of the page,
so here I grudgingly accepted the continue statement.
The code looks just like before. I’ve just added seven lines.
The exact same line indented into different levels goes all the way through a, b, c, d, e, f, and g.
Now if I run the test_words function again, I get not half a second but 0.003 seconds.
That’s nice and fast. That’s 150 times faster than before, 2000 hands per second.
The function is long and ugly, but it’s fast enough. But still I’d like to clean it up.
I don’t like repeating myself with code like this.
I don’t like that this only works exactly for seven letters.
I know that I may need more than that because there’s only seven letters
in a hand, but sometimes you combine letters in a hand with letters on the board.
This function won't be able to deal with it.